[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo en retour sur
l'actualité de la semaine dans le
département
tout de suite les titres de 100 ans
vendredi en janvier automobilistes soyez
prudents et lever le pied la vitesse
maximale passera à 30 km/heure dans tous
vivre dès le 1er février
dimanche première journée nationale de
l'hypersensibilité nous ferons point
avec notre invité
adhérente de l'association des
hypersensibles et organisatrice des
rencontres en ile-de-france lancement
des soldes top départ du paris nice
idées sorties comme chaque vendredi coup
d'oeil sur l'actualité de la semaine
mais avant en retour sur les voeux du
président de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
ils se sont déroulées hier soir
l'université est répertorié dans les
classements internationaux
une excellence que le président de
l'université alain boy espère accroître
avec la construction du paris saclay
2025 marquera l'achèvement globale de la
fusion entre l'université evry val
d'essonne et l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
écoutez les réactions
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines sera comme prévu universités
membres
d'un établissement expérimental qui va
se créer en 2020 et va préparer donc va
être complètement appliquée dans ce
d'essence était un glissement en tant
que membres associés et préparera ainsi
participera la gouvernance de cet objet
ne sera totalement appliquée à nos
formations notre recherche sont déjà on
est sommes déjà dans paris saclay mais
nous allons préparer une fusion l'enjeu
de la réussite de la france passe par
attirer des talents
d'être le sait déjà le moteur
technologique de la france c'est la
première réserve du cerveau paris-saclay
c3 mais ces trois agglomérations c'est
un pôle culturel très fort à versailles
un pôle économie très fort à saint
quentin avec beaucoup mis sur les
entreprises essentiellement qui sont là
et un pôle sur sa clé donc il faut bien
trouver un équilibre
automobilistes attention lever le pied à
partir du 1er février la vitesse sera
abaissé à 30 km/heure dans tout
villepreux une décision prise à
l'unanimité lors du conseil municipal du
18 décembre de la ville plus de
précision avec ses reportages
les automobilistes devront redoubler de
vigilance dans tout villepreux la
limitation de vitesse passera à 30 km
heure à partir du 1er février 2019 ne
vais plus de 50% des rues qui étaient
déjà à 30
donc on a décidé pour une meilleure
lisibilité donc meilleure sécurité de
tous passent à 30 km heure mais on a
aussi une ville avec beaucoup de
familles à beaucoup d'enfants
on a beaucoup d'écoles beaucoup
d'attentes maternelle dont deux
poussettes on a un collège on a un lycée
donc étant une ville très familial
il y avait un réel problème sécuritaire
gilles proulx est déjà bien équipée
toutefois de nouveaux panneaux de
limitation de vitesse seront installés
dans la ville on va mettre des panneaux
d'entrée de ville ça c'est très
important de déjà de d'annoncer dès
qu'on rentre dans la ville pour les
villes provient et les nombreux projets
que la ville est à 30
donc voyez ça va être sur les entrées de
ville et bien évidemment rajouter
quelques bonnes notes dans la ville mais
c'est à la marge
attention aux contrôles ils seront
effectués par la police municipale
après une période de prévention on va
s'adapter par rapport à l'attitude des
villes provient je peux pas savoir
aujourd'hui si des villes projets vont
être très inciviques ou pas l'objectif
n'est pas de verbaliser l'objectif c'est
faire de la prévention de la pédagogie
plusieurs communes des yvelines ont déjà
fait le choix d'abaisser la limitation à
30 km heure
c'est le cas depuis trois ans à noisy le
roi la commune voisine de villepreux
dimanche se déroule la première journée
nationale des hypersensibles derrière sa
création en nomme thomas rios saverio
tomasella il a créé et une pétition
adressée à brigitte macron en personne
dans le site challenge points alors qu
saverio tomasella epci cas
a list et écrivain il est lui même hyper
sensible en france plus de 10 millions
de personnes le sont avec moi pour en
parler amaryllis vous êtes adhérent de
l'association des hypersensibles et
organisatrice de rencontres en
ile-de-france bonjour bonjour
que signifie réellement être hyper
sensible alors il perd sensible c'est un
trait de caractère faut pas associer sa
une maladie en fait ça n'a aucun rapport
et vous qu'en fait les personnes
hypersensibles alors je parle surtout de
mon cas par exemple j'ai les 525 sens
vraiment développer c'est à dire que des
lumières trop fortes peuvent vraiment
gêner les odeurs je peux les sentir
avant d'autres personnes tout ce qui est
bruit aussi peut être gênant on a
également beaucoup du père sensibles qui
sont très créatifs donc aussi bien
chanson camp d'écriture ou en peinture
et enfin il ya deux derniers points qui
caractérise parmi tant d'autres les
hyper sensible c'est l'empathie on a une
forte empathie et une forte intuition
vous êtes membre donc de l'association
des hypersensibles le but créer du lien
social pour les personnes concernées par
l'hyper sensibilité et rompre l'
isolement
quelles sont vos actions alors en fait
nous régulièrement dans toute la france
nous proposons donc aux personnes
hypersensibles de se retrouver on crée
des rencontres dans les grosses villes
alors quand il fait beau on va dans des
parts généralement et quand il fait
moins beau généralement et dans un café
un peu plus calme où on peut échanger
sur l'hyper sensibilité se rend compte
qu'on n'est pas les seuls qu'on a
d'autres personnes comme nous qui sommes
hyper sensible des rencontres qui se
développe à nancy lyon et rennes
vous organisez donc des sorties des
voyages quel est le climat pendant ces
rencontres entre les hyper sensible
alors c'est vraiment un climat
bienveillant avec de l'ecoute de
l'empathie voilà on a un dialogue on
aborde différents thèmes
hypersensibilité aux couples
hypersensibilité au travail la parole
est libre et dans un cadre vraiment
bienveillant et ces personnes qui
viennent donc à vos ateliers vont
rencontrer vos voyages
ils savent déjà qu'ils sont
hypersensibles il ya des gens qui se
posent des questions et qui viennent par
curiosité
oui tout à fait récemment cet été il y
avait une personne qui venait pour se
rendre
si réellement il était père sensibles ou
pas elle avait un doute et puis elle
nous un petit peu définies comment elle
vivait ses émotions et on lui a fait
comprendre que oui réellement elle était
hyper sensible donc parfois des
personnes le savent déjà
dépôt de personnes ne savent pas encore
et si des personnes qui nous regardent
se pose justement cette question est-ce
que je suis hypersensible
comment le savoir eh bien par exemple la
définition que j'ai donné si si vous
aviez vraiment une forte empathie forte
intuition si vous avez vous 506 sont
assez développé un esprit créatif il ya
des fortes chances que vous soyez
hypersensible
la finalité du projet de l'association
des hypersensibles ouverture d'une
pépinière hypersensible est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur ce
projet et alan williams le président en
fait a le projet d'ouvrir son pelli le
mois de mars 2019 un centre de
ressourcement où les hyper sensibles
pourront se retrouver sur un court une
courte période à peu près six personnes
ou des ateliers de dessin de théâtre des
balades dans la nature on cuisine
également ensemble et donc on se
retrouve entre hypersensible et c'est
vraiment une bulle d'air et une petite
parenthèse dans notre quotidien en fait
des parenthèses importante pour vous et
justement à l'occasion de la première
journée nationale des hypersensibles
vous serez à paris dans le troisième au
10 rue sans clos de 10h à 18h plusieurs
conférences sont au programme première
journée nationale manifestation
importante pour vous combien attendez
vous de personnes on en attend beaucoup
je n'ai pas le chiffre mais avec tous
les médias la presse avait rios qui en
parlent beaucoup
notre page internet et nos pages
facebook je pense qu'on sera un certain
nombre donc tout le monde est le
bienvenu c'est une entrée libre
toute la journée des conférences avec
légalement une one woman show et puis
aussi le midi un partage du repas donc
chacun peut venir avec quelque chose et
puis dans un esprit convivial on ont des
jeunes rats ensemble donc c'est de 10h à
18h à paris mouvement à paris mais aussi
dans les yvelines l'association publico
propose également des ateliers à
l'occasion de cette journée les hyper
sensible en souvent comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure une grande créativité
qu'ils pourront exprimer lors des
ateliers d'écriture et de sophro
création
reposent les par un écrivain une
sophrologue et une hypnothérapeute ça se
passe dimanche dès 10 heures à la maison
des arts de morcourt exprimer sa
créativité c'est important quand on est
hyper sensible il ya beaucoup de dix
paires sensible créatif et c'est
important ça permet de mieux vivre à son
hypersensibilité et de développer cette
crise et cette qualité
donc quand on est hyper sensible on fait
plus attention aux odeurs au bruit donc
là des ateliers sont proposés
mais quelles peuvent être les autres
actions pour les hyper sensible pour
aider justement au quotidien dans cette
démarche
alors nous dans notre association des
hypersensibles on propose des ateliers
d'improvisation théâtrale aux adhérents
il faut adhérer à l'association et
également des séjours pépinière pour
mieux vivre sa sensibilité parler avec
d'autres personnes comme nous en fait on
a besoin de reconnaissance et de se
sentir à l'aise avec des personnes
qu'ils nous comprennent je le rappelle
plus de 10 millions de personnes en
france sont hypersensibles la première
journée nationale se passe dimanche et
aura lieu chaque année le 13 janvier
merci amaryllis d'avoir été avec nous
vous êtes adhérent de l'association des
hypersensibles et organisatrice de
rencontres en ile de france
certains eux seront sensibles aux bonnes
affaires c'est parti pour six semaines
de soldes avec des réductions allant
parfois jusqu'à -50%
les soldes moment phare pour les centres
commerciaux nous nous sommes rendus à
vélizy 2 au centre commercial vélizy 2
ce mercredi matin les vitrines des
magasins annonce la couleur les soldes
d'hiver ont commencé des réductions de
50% dès la première démarque
après les fêtes les premiers jours de
soldes font partie des périodes les plus
importantes pour le centre et ses 160
enseignes
toute l'équipe est prête ce que ce soit
niveau de l'accueil des équipes de
nettoyage de maintenance tout le monde
est mobilisé en fait pour accueillir nos
clients dans les meilleures conditions
dans les rayons on fouille on cherche et
on fait bien attention à l'étiquette
pour trouver les meilleures affaires moi
je vous reviens pas mal sur pente avant
il ya pas mal sur les chemins je suis
chacun sa méthode
les plus raisonnables se fixer un budget
je vous avais dépenses et ne pas
dépenser plus de 100 euros mais bon ça
dépend ce que je vais trouver et les
plus organisés viennent avec une idée
précise je suis venu chercher un
repérage que ma femme avait fait le week
end dernier donc je fais de lui acheter
une paire de chaussures les premiers
jours est il plus important en terme
d'affluence alors il fallait être sur la
ligne de départ dès ce mercredi pour
être certain de trouver chaussure à son
pied
ah oui exactement parce que pour des
chaussures après on ne trouve pas la
bonne pointure donc dans cette enseigne
de prêt-à-porter quarante mille articles
sont démarqués six semaines pour
liquider les stocks et installer les
collections printemps été
top départ également du paris-nice en
cyclisme la présentation officielle du
parcours a été rendu public ce mercredi
9 janvier à versailles
les cyclistes s'élanceront le 10 mars de
saint germain en laye le lendemain le
peloton s'élancera des bréviaires dans
le sud des yvelines
le reportage de mélanie poquet élite l
ennemi d'euros un mariage qui dure
depuis dix ans le paris-nice partira une
nouvelle fois depuis les yvelines après
ch tous les nids dernière saint germain
en laye été retenue comme ville départ
de cette 77e édition et coureurs
repartiront le dimanche 10 mars du parc
du château pour une grande boucle de 130
8 5 km à travers les imminent passant
notamment par touahri montfort l'amaury
ou encore poissy pourquoi saint germain
parce que saint germain c'est
prestigieux c'est saint germain c'est le
château parce que saint germain il ya
des perspectives formidables aussi pour
la transmission de la télé et parce
qu'on avait été super bien accueilli en
2013 dans un précédent départ de paris
nice à saint germain en laye a pas que
le paris saint-germain il ya énormément
de pratique sportive et donc c'est
important effectivement de montrer que
c'est une étape qui populaire le vélo
c'est très populaire
le lundi 11 mars à 12h35 le peloton
s'élancera des bréviaires pour une étape
de 173,5 kilomètres la petite commune de
1300 habitants située dans le sud des
yvelines deviendra la dix septième ville
du département à accueillir l'épreuve
c'est un événement historique à la fois
pour les bréviaires et pour moi
personnellement on va voir toutes les
écoles voisines qui va venir participer
avec des départs en vélo donc et puis
tout le reste de toutes les communes
voisines
il ya saint germain cité royale célèbre
son château et puis il ya de l'autre
côté les bréviaires la plus petite
commune de paris nice 2010 home on en
est ravi mais les compétitions cyclistes
c'est ça sont des grandes villes et des
villes moyennes et les petites communes
les 1300 habitants des bréviaires
pourront notamment voir en action 23
équipes cyclistes et notamment des stars
de la discipline comme le colombien
nairo quintana où les français romain
bardet ou arnaud démare mardi était un
jour attendu pour les acteurs de
l'innovation technologique puisque le
consumer electronic show débute est
organisé chaque année à las vegas plus
de 400 entreprises françaises ont fait
le déplacement pour cette édition 2010 9
parmi elles ce calme wall portal société
basée à montigny le bretonneux
pour sa quatrième participation le
reportage de nicolas d'andré ce n'est
pas un jeu vidéo mais une solution
destinée au secteur de la santé son nom
mover ce produit présenté au cs 2019 de
las vegas et conçu par la start-up sky
one portal basée à montigny le
bretonneux
je vais utiliser cet écran tactile pour
manipuler l'expérience changer la
vitesse de déplacement ajouter des
ballons des obstacles et
le forcer à effectuer certains
mouvements pour éviter les obstacles ou
attraper les ballons l'objectif c'est de
forcer le patient à effectuer certains
mouvements générés un conflit
sensorielle entre ce qu'il voit et ce
qu'il ressent physiquement
cette solution a été développée pour un
kinésithérapeute du pôle vertige
équilibre de montigny le bretonneux
déstabiliser le patient en faisant
disparaître la route accélérée ou
reculées des manipulations pour générer
un conflit sensorielle le but c'est de
les forcer à ne plus s'appuyer sur l'or
sur le visuel mais un peu plus sur leur
oreille interne ou la somme et stacy
c'est à dire le corps dans l'espace créé
en 2014 sky one portal est spécialisée
dans les solutions à usage immersive
lors du cs 2018 à las vegas la société a
créé un partenariat avec créative works
pour sa plateforme de jeu immersive
aujourd'hui créative works construit nos
produits pour le marché états unis nord
amérique australie nouvelle-zélande et
on a aussi un distributeur sur le japon
aucun marché aussi assez spécifique mais
c'est vrai que c'est aussi des
territoires où le notre solution
divertissement fonctionnant très bien
nouer des partenariats pour la
distribution des produits l'objectif de
la participation au cs avec à la clé une
activité dynamique
depuis sa création la start-up réalise
entre 50 et 100 % de croissance
qui dit vendredi dit approche du
week-end nous avons sélectionné pour
vous une idée de sortie
une exposition à la lanterne de
rambouillet elle accueille des caps là
jusqu'au 26 janvier le reportage de
marie lehn iapichino et patrick jacques
de dixmude
[Musique]
le london bridge anglais la porte de
brandebourg allemande et même la mairie
de rambouillet la ressemblance est
frappante et impressionne les visiteurs
[Musique]
ce qui est vraiment très rigolo c'est de
voir les la réaction des gens quand ils
passent la porte ils font tous la même
chose c'est-à-dire ils ont des yeux
vraiment écarquillés et c'est vrai que
c'est impressionnant pour tout le monde
de voir ce qu'ils ont réussi à faire la
lanterne souhaité une exposition ludique
et interactive
elle a été séduite par la proposition du
centre cap là
l'exposition a été montée à l'aide des
scolaires de la ville et s'est ouverte
le 5 décembre
un vrai succès environ 300 visiteurs se
rendent au pôle culturel chaque s'est
dit que ce n'est pas la tour de pise
heures pas mal comment elle tient quoi
le fait de quelques yens sans colle
aussi en plus de la visite les enfants
peuvent s'essayer à leur propre
construction avec des ateliers gratuits
animés par des membres du centre cap là
c'est bien il respecte bien et des fois
ça un peu dur mais j'arrive bien au vu
du succès du monde en cap là la lanterne
recherche déjà une nouvelle exposition
pour sa saison 2019 2020 au moins une
exposition dans les styles ça peut être
un style artistique différent mais ce
que je veux dire c'est avec un objectif
de participation de la population et de
et vraiment un objectif de rassembler
les différents agents fait notamment les
enfants et des jeunes
vous avez jusqu'au 26 janvier pour
reconnaître la sagrada familia de
barcelone
et encore le port de copenhague
[Musique]
l'actualité dans le reste de l'île de
france avec nos confrères devient grand
paris chaîne disponible sur la tnt et
aujourd'hui nous parlerons du vélidio ce
vélo à assistance électrique
en ile-de-france le but encourager les
franciliens à laisser leur voiture au
garage développer l'usagé faciliter
l'utilisation du vélo en ile de france
c'est le nouveau défi d'ile-de-france
mobilité se déplacer en vélo jusqu'à la
gare ou au travail et laisser sa voiture
au garage
voici le v league aux vélos à assistance
électrique de la région ile de france
il circulera bientôt dans la petite et
grande couronne francilienne pour la
région le défi est de taille
inciter plus de deux cent mille
personnes à pédaler multiplié par trois
le nombre de cyclistes sur des trajets
entre 5 et 10 km et l'objectif c'est
donc de polluer moins d'avoir moins de
voitures et puis aussi de faire du sport
santé parce que le vélo c'est bon pour
pour le stress c'est bon pour le
physique pour atteindre les 2 millions
de trajets en 2021
la région a imaginé le plus large de
services de location de vélos
électriques au monde
vingt mille deux roues d'ici 2020 en ile
de france nous allons mettre en plus de
ces vélos des parkings sécurisés velits
go aux portes des gares et aux portes de
paris de façon à ce qu'on puisse laisser
son vélo et ne pas le laisser traîner
dans la rue toute la journée
contrairement au vélib la région mis sur
des abonnements longue durée de six à
neuf mois maximum à l'issue de cette
période
l'usager aura la possibilité d'acheter
le vélo côté tarifs comptez 40 euros par
mois la moitié pourra être remboursé par
l'employeur
début des réservations mois de mai pour
l'utiliser il faudra patienter jusqu'à
septembre prochain
dix mille vélos seront mises en service
avant de refermer notre édition notre
rendez vous ça s'est passé chaque
semaine nous ouvrons des archives re
pour revenir sur l'actualité locale
cette semaine direction 2015 avec les
marches républicaine organisée au
lendemain des attentats qui ont touché
la rédaction charlie hebdo et le magasin
hyper cacher à paris regardez
[Musique]
une fois de plus tous unis derrière une
seule volonté rendre hommage aux
victimes et dire non à la barbarie avec
pour unité le drapeau bleu blanc rouge
et je suis charlie un rassemblement
d'élus et de citoyens
alors je pense que le message est bien
sûr et très très très important c'est
l'avenir de notre pays quelque part qui
se joue depuis quelques heures
et dire écoutez c'est aussi pour
représentant de la république de porter
ces messages ce que nous avons fait
d'une façon très très humble aujourd'hui
à rambouillet mais avec aussi beaucoup
de force
oui ici de l'émotion mais de l'eau mais
l'émotion combattante et avec toute la
force qui nous unis ont lavé aujourd'hui
haranguer nous entre en résistance pour
que nos libertés soient sauvés je suis
abdelkader j'en suis fier
mais ma république est fière aussi
d'avoir abdelkader à la tête d'une
circonscription telle que celle de
rambouillet chercher d'histoire changer
de toute l'histoire de la france c'est
pas une réaction en particulier à
charlie hebdo ça aurait pu être le
canard ça aurait pu être n'importe quel
autre journal c'est c'est la même chose
on tue la liberté d'expression charlie
hebdo était bien sûr réputé pour ses
caricatures les traits de crayon célèbre
de cabu charb et tant d'autres leur mort
a éveillé chez certains robots lutins
des envies de prendre le crayon
j'ai eu envie de ses pages à veiller
j'ai un copain dans le photo club
bouchut qui avait fait 1
j'avais fait un croquis puis le cas je
me suis mis devant le fait de papier
puis j'ai j'ai laissé faire le crayon
passé tout comme ça c'est clair
un moyen de
pour rendre hommage c'est un bien grand
mot mais j'ai eu envie de faire je les
fais dans cette marche républicaine se
côtoyaient toutes les générations et
même les citoyens de demain
une occasion pour certains parents de
partager leurs valeurs
la semaine a été très difficile avant
tôt pour nous et aussi pour eux c'était
un choc pour toute la famille on leur a
transmis
qu'est ce qu'on a ressenti nous mais et
on a été touchés droite au coeur voilà
on a pu leur transmettre ce qu'on se
sait en quoi on croit et ce en quoi on
pense
dix mille personnes ont défilé à
rambouillet s'ajoutant ainsi aux près de
4 millions de français qui se sont
rassemblés un peu partout dans le pays
faisant de cette journée un événement
historique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo passer
un excellent week-end retour de
l'information lundi à 18 heures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]